wait for it well I knew that was going
to happen but in real life we rarely get
advance notice for a disruptive event
stay tuned as we discuss how to build a
solid business continuity plan I'm
Priyanka and welcome to you and those
101 many of you might have backup and
disaster recovery plans in place but we
rarely get notified that a disruptive
event might happen even with some lead
time things can still go wrong and
impact business continuity let's answer
seven key questions that can help you go
beyond traditional backup and dr
question number one are your
applications are detective for high
availability and data redundancy and
those gke helps you architect for high
availability and data redundancy by
offering two types of clusters zonal and
regional in a zonal cluster topology a
clusters control plane and nodes all run
in a single computes own that you
specify when you create the cluster in a
regional cluster masters and nodes are
replicated across multiple zones within
a single region regional clusters
consist of a three masters quorum
offering higher availability than a
zonal cluster you can minimize the risk
of disruption to your services as well
as expedite the upgrade process through
unique features like surge upgrades and
release channels and those also enables
data protection through disk snapshot
stored in any regional or multi regional
locations across Google cloud and disks
can be attached to regional clusters and
failover if a zone fails you can combine
these with Ando's enabled software from
the Google cloud marketplace to enable
high availability applications such as
Kasten 10 port works enterprise robin
storage Optronics ApS question number
two can your app scale up and down
without code changes when you walk with
anthos you are adopting modern cloud
native technologies like containers sir
servus mesh that enables micro-services
based applications these are modular
architectures that make it easier to
upgrade and scale up and down then a
tightly coupled monolithic application
question number three do you have
consistent management across on-prem and
multi cloud environments we started the
series by answering the question what is
an tha's where we covered how add those
can help you consistently secure and
operate existing apps develop and deploy
new apps across disparate locations
while offering centralized visibility
and management of resources question
number four are you finding and fixing
bugs before moving to production well
the only way to shift bug-free code is
by catching bugs and fixing them before
deployment with increasing adoption of
hybrid and multi cloud you need a modern
CI CD pipeline to automatically build
tests and reliably deploy to different
environments to learn more about how to
build a modern CI CD pipeline with
anthos check out a previous episode
question number five have you defined
and implemented measurable service level
objectives or as allows for your apps
it's crucial to define RTO and RPO for
business continuity RTO or recovery time
objective is the amount of time an
application can be unavailable without
causing significant damage to your
business our Bo or recovery point
objective is the tolerance of how much
data can be lost before critically
impacting your business it helps to
consider modernizing your existing
applications to cloud native
architecture this will help you deliver
uninterrupted services and an optimal
cost with Ando's you can easily set as
allows for your services and monitor
them that brings me to question number
six
can you proactively mitigate failures in
your applications and those dashboards
provides built-in SLO so you can improve
the observability and proactively
mitigate failures just like Google
Sarris for more details check out how to
improve observability using golden
signals episode in the anthems 101
series question number seven do you have
access to skills to develop and maintain
your abs now this might sound like a
learning problem but having a
standardized technology platform which
makes it easy for you to manage existing
applications and build new ones helps
with Ando's your team's have access to
skills to develop and maintain apps not
just in one environment but across
multiple environments to summarize
here's a checklist of how to go beyond
business continuity with anthos develop
high availability apps with data
redundancy scale flexibly without code
changes find and fix bugs before moving
into production manage consistently
across on-prem and multi-cloud implement
measurable asilo still and RPO values
mitigate app failures proactively gain
sufficient access to skills today we
learned that anthos can help you build a
next gen business continuity plan beyond
traditional backup and disaster recovery
read beyond business continuity white
paper linked below to learn more
and for more anthos content don't forget
to subscribe and check out the entire
enthis 101 playlist
[Music]